Ireland's Deputy Prime Minister has said
the government's brexit proposals are
unacceptable as they stand while the EU
has described them as bad ideas that
have been repackaged so can they be the
basis for a brexit deal joining us from
Westminster is Lord Jones the former
trade minister and former head of the
Confederation of British industry Lord
DB Jones thanks for joining us on the
program what are you thinking of it all
well I actually find it very encouraging
there are three constituencies here
really aren't there there are the people
the people of Britain and I get around
the country small businesses big
businesses different sectors people who
work in those businesses as well as on
them and they've all had enough and all
of us in the West Minister bubble are
completely disconnected with what the
country actually wants they want it
sorted they want it delivered they've
had enough and I think anybody in the
House of Commons or in the House of
Lords should just for once lift their
eyes up to a horizon that goes past
Westminster so they're one constituency
that's going to welcome this I reckon
the second one is the House of Commons
and in there and I thought your piece
just before we went to that very brave
Alec's in Hong Kong the piece there I
thought the analysis there was
absolutely right which is that bit by
bit Boris can bring the different
parties back in - I went sent a line I
think that's insulting but certainly
seeing the worth of trying to get this
deal through so quite a few members of
the European Union report group the ones
who are hardline they 21 who walked the
floor on the extension bill they'll come
back there'll be quite a few labour you
know who aren't necessarily brexit ears
but who are going to think if we go into
a constituency and say we were to blame
for not getting it done when everybody
else was there we might lose our jobs I
think there'll be quite a few Labour MPs
who at the end of the day will refuse
any obstructive whip from Corbin on the
point of let's bring down this
government let's do anything to hurt the
tour is that sort of argument a domestic
agenda if you like
and I think they will see it in a wider
picture hope so and then of course
you've got the DUP in Ireland who in
Northern Ireland who about she said yeah
we can we can work with this and then
you've got the third one okay and this
is the one that you referred to in your
intro and that is the European Union now
the one thing that has been a
characteristic of negotiations and
indeed the personalities involved from
Michel Barnier to jean-claude Juncker
and Donald Tusk the one thing they've
never wanted to do is be blamed they
want all the blame to be on Britain you
voted to come out you take the
consequence you come here with an offer
we're not it's not our fault there's a
lot of that and it's subliminal they
don't ever use words like that but that
that is where they are and what is
happening if you're seeing the EU being
maneuvered into a position where they
will be seen as the blockage and that is
a place they don't want to be and so
quite how Berlin because you know Berlin
bosses Europe they pay the piper they
call the tune it's not an anti German
thing to say they're good people
but they do pay the piper and they do
call the tune quite how Berlin gets
Paris to agree and then especially the
two of them together get Dublin to agree
so that the tea shook vodka can actually
come to understand that there is a
practical application here of all the
words and all the clauses there's a
practical way through this that Northern
Ireland agreed to if they can put the
pressure on there and if the council of
ministers on the 16th century in october
can say we can see this working because
we don't want to be blamed for the 31st
of october Armageddon then I can see
this happening I can actually see
something happening by the 31st and did
any of us you me or anybody else ever
think that a couple of weeks ago what a
very fulsome answer thank you for that
but you know the bottom line is we've
got a problem with the Northern Ireland
border the border between Northern
Ireland and the rest of Island that can
only be fixed with either a border being
put back in place or a backstop or is
there another alternative well yeah I
don't quite agree with your conclusion
there is a choice because what is now
being proposed is yes a bit of
technology but actually a different
status for Northern Ireland to the rest
of Britain for a period of time whilst a
border can be developed that doesn't
involve a border if you like give me a
full inch that is the dup say no thank
you
well the DUP actually haven't said no
thank you
but what they are and indeed what Alan
is saying is can we trust this to work
and I'd make one plea for that Kay
actually which is why not let the
businesses the business women in the
business men big business small business
and either side of the Northern Irish
Island border let it work make it work
get it to work
businesses innovative they spend their
careers making sure that they can wade
through stuff and get it to happen and
in that respect to come up with this
different idea so that they actually can
have one customs union and then out with
the UK for a period of time business can
make the practical application of this
work now and I would just ask
politicians trouble of politicians is
you know they they don't understand
business they don't understand how it
works more importantly very few of them
have actually worked in it so they sort
of just think oh no this won't work
I trust the businesses in Ireland in the
Republic of Ireland and in Northern
Ireland and in the UK and frankly in the
rest of Europe to make this work because
it's in their interests and if it's in
their interests they make money if they
make money they pay tax if the pay tax
you and I get another school in hospital
okay so we did speak to a business owner
on the border and he said his
interpretation with this to broader rule
would be as you know it has to be
approved every four years it's doubling
of the red tape and for many businesses
that's just too much all right well
that's two that's two conclusions the
first one it's a doubling of red tape I
agree I would say that it's only for a
period of time this is not forever it'll
all get sorted out in the transition
we move through and into a trading
agreement for everywhere and if you get
a quality trading agreement between the
United Kingdom including Northern
Ireland and the rest of Europe all of
this goes away because the trading
agreement will contain provisions for
how it works and by then the UK will be
out so it's not forever but the second
point which is and they don't want to
extra red tape and extra burocracy I
actually agree with them I get I get the
complaint all I would say to them is you
can we'll deal with that in the short
term it'll it'll annoy you frustrate you
but you can deal with it because the
alternative is worse okay Lord Digby
Jones good to talk to you as always
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thanks thanks very much